so we're going to talk about the number
8,000 128 it's a famous type of number
called perfect number now this was the
largest perfect number known in
antiquity or for a very long time but
what is a perfect number
the smallest perfect number is the
number six let's look at the number six
now what does it mean what divides into
six
well one divides into six that's always
true two divides into six and three
divides into six now six does divide as
well but for what we're going to do
we're going to ignore the number itself
so ignore six if we add up the numbers
that divide six one two and three add
them together and we get the number six
we get the number itself so this is a
perfect number because the divisors add
up to the number itself it's not too
small and it's not too big it's just
right it's perfect and in antiquity they
were given this rare perfect property so
the next one after six is the number
twenty-eight let's write that down
28 so what divides 28 add these together
and you get the number 28 it's the
second perfect number
the third perfect number after that bit
of a gap after that the third perfect
number is 496 for nine six let's look at
the divisors of this we've got one quite
a few of these to 60 to 120 for 248
running off the edge we add all this
together in the same ways before we get
496 again it's perfect now there's only
one perfect number between one and ten
that's the number six there's only one
perfect number between 10 and 100 that's
28 there's only one perfect number
between a hundred and a thousand 496 and
there is only one perfect number between
a thousand and ten thousand and that is
eight thousand one hundred and twenty
eight let's try it out then okay one two
four eight two thousand and thirty-two
and 4064 4064 add those together in the
same way and you will get 8000 128 today
even with our computers that can compute
massive numbers we have only found 47
perfect numbers that is all four were
known to the ancient Greeks still today
21st century 47 we've got there may be
more there may not be we don't know if
there's an infinite many of these
numbers and that's an open question
you'd think that that's something we
would know by now are there infinitely
many of these are aren't there we don't
know the answer to that yet what's the
biggest perfect number
it's so far I would murder a spy out the
largest perfect number hmm well hey the
WolframAlpha says do you mean largest
integer
there's no larges integer so that's
helpful
interestingly and we don't know if there
are odd perfect numbers either all the
perfect numbers we have found are even
as another question we don't know the
largest known perfect number is
apparently 1 million seven hundred and
ninety one thousand digits long don't
ask me to say it we could be here till
next week but that is the full thing
nearly 2 million digits long
I could be scrolling for quite some time